It became apparent rather quickly that,
that it was a bigger deal than maybe I thought. Um,
cause I was mostly just annoyed that, that I had to,
I had to deal with it at all.
Go back to the beginning. The thing that sort of made you a national figure,
although you were a Congressman already, uh,
let's talk about Saturday night live.
I'm sure you've never talked about that before. Right. Maybe, maybe once,
maybe twice. Can you just talk a little bit about that night? You see,
you see the Pete Davidson sketch and then just sort of all the fallout and then
what you did ultimately, was it literally, I think the next week when you,
when you went on the show, um,
and just talk about how that then sort of set you up to be a more national
figure instead of just a, you know, a Congressman from, from Texas.
Yeah. Um, well obviously I wasn't, I wasn't really watching it that night.
Of course, you know, nobody is right. I think most people, uh,
digest the most people digest Saturday night live from like the next day's
YouTube videos or something. Um, if it's a good skit and that's,
that was no different on this one,
of course that story started getting written about it. Um, I had not seen it.
I had some funny text messages from my buddies that were just giving me a hard
time for it. You know, we have a very dark sense of humor in the teams and, um,
it became apparent rather quickly that,
that it was a bigger deal than maybe I thought. Um,
cause I was mostly just annoyed that I had to, I had to deal with it at all.
Um, it was, uh, it was, there was a lot going on that day.
That was the Sunday before the election. Um, you know,
we were doing pretty well, but uh,
but I had a lot of events I had to get to and um,
it felt more like an annoyance. I was not,
I was not used to having to respond publicly to things probably the way I'm more
used to that. Now.
The one sentence recap of, of what the skit was or what the line was.
Sure, sure. So yeah,
Pete Davidson was basically going down a list of a quote unquote gross people,
all politicians, um, all, all except for one were Republican.
And um, he basically just makes fun of everybody. But with me, he, you know,
at first he's like this guy,
he looks kind of like a Hitman and a porno and that was pretty funny to be
honest. Um, but, but uh, then he goes off, sorry, like, you know,
he lost his eye and war or whatever. Right.
And it was that it was that single line that,
that seems so dismissive of a war injury that just injured people nuts. And,
um, and understandably so. And um,
now the way I analyzed this and the way I analyze it in my book, um,
is,
is it was pretty obvious that he was trying to take a dig at
conservatives, right? It is it's the Davidson it's Saturday night live it,
they dig it Democrats plenty too. But, um, but on this particular skit,
it was a very clear swipe at conservatives, um, because the
it's obvious just, just watch it. Um,
but it wasn't as it was not as obvious that that he was trying to
insult, um, wounded veterans, you know? And so there was a,
there was the thought process the next day was okay,
how much grace can we give here while still,
while still acknowledging that many veterans are hurt by this like genuinely
they're, they're off and maybe they have good reason to be,
but also I don't want to unleash this outrage mob because one, I don't feel it.
You know, I just,
I genuinely don't feel like the sense of being offended and that's just not who
I am.
And so I don't want to express something that I'm not really feeling either. Um,
which seems to be the norm and the surprising thing about all this was that it
was so surprising to people that I wouldn't unleash the outrage mob.
And I said something along, you know, my, my main quote from that was, you know,
a quote that I actually stole from a Harvard professor,
which was a try hard not to offend people, try even harder, not to be offended.
You know, the joke wasn't very funny, but like,
I'm not going to call it for this guy to get fired. I'm not going to like,
you know, demand that everybody cancels Saturday night live. It's just,
it seems, it's just that felt wrong. And so it didn't do it. And, um,
that gave Saturday night live the space to actually apologize the way they want
it to and have me on.
And I talk about this in my chive all chapter about the right sense of shame.
And this is the only time I bring up the Saturday night live thing.
And the book that the book kind of came about because of the fame that I got
from Saturday night live. But the book isn't really about that, um, it's just,
it just so happens that I,
I was directly involved in sort of an outrage culture moment.
And so I decided to write a whole book about the solutions to outrage culture.
And, but that moment it takes up like three pages of the book. Um,
not even, um,
but what I point out is that there's a right way to show shame in our culture
and there's a wrong way. And more and more and more,
our culture is going a little wrong way where we have like these two extreme
options on the one hand, people will bow down to the outrage from I'm so sorry.
I can't believe I did that. And I, I bring up some examples in the book, um,
on that, uh, w one w one,
because this one just drove me nuts was Mario Lopez when he makes the all to,
uh, understandable comment that three-year-olds should not choose their gender.
I mean, Oh my God can't even,
even believe he said that he got paid for it. Right.
And then, but what does he do? He doesn't say, Hey, hold on,
what's wrong with that? You know, come on guys like that. He doesn't do that.
He says, Oh my God, I'm so sorry. I'm so, so sorry, please, please forgive me.
Right. That's the wrong sense of shame.
And there's on the other extreme, there's another wrong sense of shame,
which is showing no shame at all. And there's plenty of examples like that,
mostly in the political world, but other,
but in other places as well and other public figures.
And then I diagnosed like the re why is that? Like, why,
why is there this incentive for, or the other? And it's,
and it's an all of us problem.
It's not just our terrible politicians or silly celebrities.
It's an all of us problem.
We all engage in this shaming in the wrong way. We either, we,
we, we overreact to such an extent that we force people to bow down when they
shouldn't,
or we overreact to such an extent that public figures realize there's no
incentive to apologize because there's no forgiving. There's no,
there's no redemption. There's no forgetting like,
and so we have to get back to this sort of middle ground and people.
And there's good examples that I bring up in the book of that good middle ground
too. Um, and we,
we just have to do more of that and be more nuanced in our thinking nuances,
like a huge part of solving this problem.
Yeah. So you,
you go back on SNL and there's humor and there's nuance and decency and all of
those things and that kind of propels you. And one of the things,
things that I think is sort of interesting about you is it's like,
we've sort of got these cartoon characters on the left with the squad,
like AOC and Alon Omar, and to leave and a couple others.
And then there's sort of you on the other side of that. And when you,
when you take you and the eyepatch, there's sort of like,
you're kind of like Nick fury,
like if we're looking at this through a marble lens, it's like,
there's as we should, as we should. Right. I mean, but I mean,
we're sort of like,
there's like all the politicians now it's soil and Trump and everybody has sort
of like characters in a movie or in a video game or something like that.
But I mentioned this because it's like,
it seems like there's this young crew from the lefties,
and then there's sort of you on the other side of that,
are there some other guys that you got guys, girls, whatever that,
that you think are in your crew that are sort of the younger more,
get it more willing to open up, talk about these things. I mean, I, you know,
I've done events with you where like, you know,
you can be out there with the students and it's not this stuffy thing,
but it seems like it's kind of just you holding that for the,
for the sort of new, more, maybe open-minded conservative, something like that.
Yeah.
That's a good question. I do get asked that a lot. And, um,
it's a difficult question because like,
I don't want to try and analyze the minds of my colleagues who maybe don't put
themselves out there as much. I think maybe a lot would be willing to,
but they don't have the same ability to, or they're not sure how, um,
there's some really great members of Congress who are, who are our age, um,
you know, uh, like Mike Gallagher, at least to phonic and, uh,
they're out there, but you know, they, they, they, they have their own style.
They're not on social media the way I am. They're not out there the way I am.
Everybody does have their own style. Um,
I'm excited about sort of a new squad coming out of Texas. Uh, we,
we've got a lot of great new, um, candidates running, a very diverse set,
very young. Uh, I I'm really excited about it. Um, you know,
I've got Wesley hunt here next to me.
African-American army helicopter pilot got Tony Gonzalez running for Willard's
seat, uh, old master chief, not, not old, sorry, but prior master chief,
um, you know, Beth van Dyne, she's a prior mayor again, young,
like got a lot of like very intelligent, got a lot of spunk, um, uh, Genevieve,
Colin's another great one. Again, young woman millennial like me, um, you know,
very successful, got a great shot at that seat. There's,
there's a lot of really good, uh, candidates.
I think the Republican party does have a chance to like really remake itself,
um, in, in a really big way that that connects with a lot of different people.
So I'm, uh, I'm excited about it.
Yeah. Is the biggest challenge there,
just getting over sort of the old stereotypes. I mean, just the old stereotypes,
conservatives care about money and care about war and re you know,
Democrats like poor people and peace,
like these basic sort of very factory setting things. When, when in reality,
I mean, we spoke at the turning point student action summit,
and Trump spoke that morning and it was right after the, uh,
the impeachment hearing. And you want it to get up in the middle of his speech.
You were trying to show him your vote, that you voted against it.
And it was like, it was a totally impromptu moment.
Trump looks at you in the crowd. He's like, Dan, come on up here. The secret,
the secret service guys were all looking like, Oh God,
now we have to get this guy from the crowd, even though he's a Congressman,
get him on stage. But, but my,
my broader point is that it was like fun and real,
which is so the reverse of what politics is presented to us
as.
Yeah. Oh yeah. I mean,
it's totally changed in the last few years and I think it's exciting now we have
to be responsible with, with how we manage this new train.
That's just like lurching forward, right? Because it is this sort of, uh,
interesting combination of like showmanship, uh,
with, with some deep thinking and some,
some real actual statesmanship. Um,
it is up to us as leaders to make sure that we,
that we maintain those bonds and,
and mend them in a very coherent way.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.